pretty fired up brand new website for V  friends  dot com uh vcon I want to see all of you  there new super business culture  marketing conference but vfriends.com if  you own a v-friend book games  series two iconics mini drop or a series  one or series two the new website is up  go verify your account right now because  I've got a ton of [ __ ] coming up that  are going to be token gated teased with  garyvee's interviews Live Events random  surprising Delights it's about to really  really happen in V friends land and a  lot of you bought and forgot so please  go to befriends.com link is in my bio  right now to the new website so that you  can go and verify your account love you  see you